Carrusel de las artes
[Música]
María Carolina piña
Bienvenidos a este programa donde la
cultura es noticia estamos muy contentos
de presentarles este Carrusel de las
artes desde nuestros estudios aquí en
París y a continuación los temas que les
hemos preparado para hoy
el tango abraza la historia de amor más
conocida y dramática de la literatura un
Romeo y Julieta tanguero se estrenó en
París es uno de los autores franceses de
historietas más leídos del momento
Carrusel de las artes pasó tres minutos
con riad satuff
en los estrenos del cine francés una
comedia de bandidos el inocente del
actor y ahora también director Luis
gagela y en nuestra Crónica musical
conoceremos a la multifacética terrestre
artista emergente estilista modelo y
militante su música mezcla pop
sonoridades electrónicas y asiáticas
[Música]
Romeo y Julieta la tragedia de William
Shakespeare inspirado numerosos vales y
hasta un musical que luego fue llevado
al cine y en El Siglo 21 artistas
argentinos adaptaron esta historia al
tango en un espectáculo que se estrenó
aquí en Francia
Los amantes más conocidos de la
literatura se trasladan de Verona a
Buenos Aires es lo que cuenta Esta
adaptación libre de Romeo y Julieta con
10 bailarines de Tango apasionada
festiva y sensual que se estrenó en
París en las calles de Buenos Aires
[Música]
una tragedia y es una comedia y tiene
como muchísimos matices que tiene el
tango no como la pasión la muerte
el odio El engaño La traición y son como
todos matices que me parecía que se era
como que el ADN era muy similar para
ambos y efectivamente el lenguaje del
tango tenía muchísimo que ver porque
cuando empezamos a analizar los cinco
actos que tiene la pieza de Shakespeare
me di cuenta que cada acto era un
sentimiento y todos esos sentimientos
tenían que ver con el tango
[Música]
Romeo y Julieta se conocen y declaran su
amor bailando en los roles protagónicos
dos bailarines no argentinos sino
griegos que se enamoraron del tango
Yo pienso que el tango es la el baile
ideal para representar Romeo y Julieta
para mí Romeo y Julieta representan a la
pareja romántica
que pasa de todo el proceso de
encontrarse enamorarse y después la
separación en la tragedia al final
Julieta en esta obra pasa por todo eso y
el tango le ayuda para expresar todos
estos estados
[Música]
la hora es muy exigente porque tiene
todo tiene suelo tiene tasas
contemporánea tiene chat tiene saltos
tiene mucha cosas la tragedia todo que
pasa para mí representa es como el
trabajo que hacemos en las parejas en la
vida
milonga tango tradicional y danza
moderna se acompañan de una partitura
original para este espectáculo
[Música]
el tango lleva a Romeo y Julieta a un
lugar un poco más más actual hay partes
de la adaptación donde realmente se ve
bueno mucha pasión donde hay mucho
cuerpo donde hay mucha sensualidad y
creo que esto el tango puntualmente le
aporta esto a Romeo y Julieta poder
exprimir ese lado de la obra que por ahí
en la historia original es algo un poco
más nariz
[Música]
les presentamos a continuación a uno de
los autores de historieta franceses más
apreciados por chicos y adultos se llama
riad satuff y lo conocemos de la mano de
Melissa barra
[Música]
que tienen en común los adolescentes de
las aulas francesas y aquellos de un
pequeño pueblo en Siria La respuesta es
el ojo del historietista y cineasta
riaza
estoy obsesionado con hacer historietas
para gente que no lee historietas tres
minutos con
[Música]
nacido en París de padres sirio y madre
francesa se crió en Libia en Siria y
luego en Bretaña Francia una experiencia
que lo llevó a publicar la serie de
historietas el árabe del futuro
guardo en mi memoria todos los recuerdos
de infancia esta historieta cuenta ante
todo la vida de mi padre un intelectual
árabe que venía de un entorno muy pobre
y Era De cierto modo un árabe de
ultraderecha es la historia de su
familia de nosotros en el mundo árabe de
los años 80
contrastes culturales y sociales
conservadurismo y progresismo también ve
el mundo a través de su cámara y siempre
con mucho humor como en las Cintas
satírica raquí en el reino de las chicas
que cuenta la vida bajo una dictadura
militar al estilo talibán Pero donde las
mujeres dominan y los hombres con velo
se sometelo
[Aplausos]
pero el tema que más ha exploradora en
sus comedias y en sus historietas es la
niñez y la adolescencia un periodo de
acné hormonas cuestionamientos y
complejos que retrató en su primera
cinta presentada en canness en 2009
[Música]
la película llegó a la estrellato a su
actor fetiche vean son Lacoste una
trayectoria que también inmortalizó en
una historieta El joven actor
contar su trayectoria fue muy divertido
porque a él no le apasionaba el cine
quería Mostrar como uno puede revelarse
a través del arte y la expresión
artística siendo inicialmente a alguien
totalmente común y corriente
chicos y también chicas porque su serie
de historieta y animación más extensa se
llama los cuadernos de steg pase tiempo
con la hija de una pareja de amigos que
tenía 10 años y que era muy parlanchina
Me contaba todo lo que ocurría en el
colegio y su visión del mundo y me
pareció que eran muy buenas historias
acordamos que íbamos a contar su vida en
historietas hasta sus 18 años
[Música]
pasamos ahora nuestro bloque de cine que
en esta ocasión dedicamos a una comedia
dirigida y protagonizada por uno de los
artistas más prometedores del momento
llega a las salas de cine el inocente
una cinta inspirada en la juventud del
actor y ahora director de cine Luis Gael
Aquí
esta comedia relata las peripecias de
Abel un chico que descubre que su madre
está perdidamente enamorada de un hombre
que acaba de salir de prisión y junto a
su amiga clemos Abel tratará de proteger
a su madre la película recuerda a las
cintas de mafiosos de los años 70 pero
con un toque de humor el apuesto Luis
Gael se puso detrás y frente a la cámara
en esta cinta presentada en el último
festival de cine de canés
pienso que reúne tres géneros el
policíaco la comedia romántica y la
comedia es un policíaco familiar en el
que mi personaje se entera que su madre
se va a casar con un ex Presidiario
es casi como un relato picaresco y de
aventura en el que dos mundos diferentes
se cruzan de forma íntima el de un ex
delincuente y el de un hijo y del
conflicto nacen nuevas perspectivas
Espero que el público lo encuentre
cónico
[Música]
ahora ya de nuestra Crónica musical con
Natalia Olivares quien ya se encuentra
en nuestros estudios Natalia hoy nos
presentas a una joya musical se llama
terrest y es un artista total es un
artista Total como lo dices para
resumirla esa experta en crear mundos
diversos llenos de lentejuela y brilla
sobre todo por su personalidad fuerte y
su espontaneidad y suena Así
[Música]
cuando sacuda
ella escribió esta canción que se llama
shineas para enfrentar las
discriminaciones y los clichés ella
tiene orígenes de China de Vietnam de
laos y ahora está haciendo un nuevo
proyecto musical nos habló de ello y se
llama yalos
[Música]
esta canción nació de mi observación
como persona celosa o envidiada en el
sector de la industria musical estoy
hablando de celos sociales es importante
subrayarlo porque a veces cuando
hablamos de celos son celos románticos
pero aquí estoy hablando del fenómeno de
esta sociedad que nos lleva
constantemente a compararnos a estar en
competencia y ahora más con la era de
las redes sociales Y de pronto el camino
a seguir en mi opinión sería trabajar
esta Falta de confianza precisamente
para hacer cada vez menos celosas y
celosos
[Música]
ella no tiene límites terrestres de
multifacética es influencer es música
dibuja es modelo también se Sube arriba
de los podios va a las redes sociales
etcétera incluso hasta la avala las
escuelas y por eso Muchos las llaman la
mujer arcoiris
[Música]
para este lado multifacético que puedo
tener es sorprendente pero no siento que
estoy haciendo Muchos trabajos al mismo
tiempo Solo tengo una idea que defender
Y eso pasa por muchos soportes
diferentes no tengo la sensación de ser
varias personas al mismo tiempo o a lo
mejor sí pero al final no importa qué
tanto problema si quiero hacer de todo
si quiero hacer música si quiero hacer
estilismo si quiero ser activista y
ciertamente le tengo miedo pero las
ganas son más fuertes y de repente voy a
ir a explorar voy a salir mal voy a ir
contra la pared pero no importará porque
sé que me levantaré
[Música]
ella milita por un feminismo inclusive
inclusivo una identidad sexual y
cultural sin discriminaciones donde saca
de dónde saca tanta energía bueno la
pregunta y La respuesta es de una
enfermedad de una enfermedad hereditaria
que le viene de su mamá Y todo empezó
cuando los médicos le anunciaron ese
diagnóstico Irreversible
me di cuenta en ese preciso momento que
yo era potencialmente mortal y fue este
enfrentamiento con la muerte potencial
lo que me hizo pensar que la vida es
corta y que no podía permitir perder ni
una amiga del tiempo voy a tener que
parar un tiempo en medio del impulso de
mi carrera me pareció muy Injusto al
principio pero hoy me digo a mí misma
que la vida sabe y probablemente sacaré
una bella experiencia Tengo fe veremos
qué pasa
[Música]
gracias Natalia por presentarnos y con
este tema ya luz para que no seamos ni
celosos ni celosas vamos a terminar este
Carrusel de las artes agradeciéndoles
por su amable sintonía y hasta la
próxima Bye
[Música]
seguimos si nos Simón